C'C'est l'heure de notre panel
popolitique avec Josée Legault,
PaPaul Wells et Michel David.
- - Je vais vous faire entendre
MoMonsieur Berthold, député
coconservateur, qui a lancé un
apappel aujourd'hui aux
mamanifestants de rentrer à l la
mamaison. Monsieur cigne, qui
dédénonce l'inaction du
gogouvernement Trudeau et Blanct
ququi dit que ça ne se peut pas!
LULUC BERTHOLD, lieutenant pol.
QcQc, Parti conservateur du Cana
- - À ces manifestants ici,
àà O Ottawa, vous êtetes venus
a a été entendu, les conservates
vovous ont entendus et nous vous
dédéfendrons, ainsi que tous
leles Canadiens qui veulent
rereprendre la vie telle que
nonous la connaissions.
EtEt, Madame la présidente, soyz
asassurée que nous n'arrêteteros
papas tant que le confinement et
leles obligations vaccinales ne
seseront pas terminées.
JAJAGMEET SINGH, chef,
NoNouveau Parti démocratique
- - Et c'est aussi inacceptable
quque le premier ministre
d'd'un pays du G7, un des pays
leles plus puissants au monde,
n'n'agisse pas, ne montrait pas
dede leadership pour régler cete
sisituation. Et particulièrerem,
c'c'est complètetement inaccepte
ququ'un poste frontalier le plus
imimportant de l'Amérique du Nod
esest fermé en ce moment
àà W Windsor, au pont Ambassado.
YVYVES-FRANÇOIS BLANCHET,
chchef, Bloc québécois
- - Il y a de possibles
dédéveloppements extrêmemement
trtroublants à O Ottawa
etet ailleurs à t travers le Caa
prprésentement. Est-ce que le
prpremier ministre peut convoqur
leles chefs de partis
àà u une rencontre d'urgence?
- - Je suis en contact étroit
avavec des partenaires
auaux différents paliers de
gogouvernement, des conversatios
avavec d'autres parlementaires,
etet je suis très s content d'or
auau chef du Bloc un breffage
popour qu'il soit mis à j jour.
- - Il y aura dans quelques heus
unune Josée Legault, je ne sais
papas si vous avez pu entendre
PaPablo gaz, qui dit que c'était
lala police d'Ottawa pour Ottawa
etet la police de Windsor pour e
popont.
- - Ça fait deux semaines que ça
dudure Ottawa, on a aussi le
blblocage du pont ambassadeur qi
cocoûtete extrêmemement cher ett
lala réputation du Canada. On a
auaussi les convois. Cette
ininaction sur le plan politique
vava commencer à c coûteter au
gogouvernement libéral s'il n'ya
papas quelque chose de fait. Je
cocomprends l'argument de Monsir
RoRodriguez que ce n'est pas au
gogouvernement fédéral a appelé
l'l'armée, il faudrait que le
prpremier ministre de l'Ontarion
faface de la demande, il y a pe-
êêtrtre des solutions avant
l'l'armée. Il y a un prix
popolitique qui va se payer, mas
l'l'important pour le moment,
c'c'est que les résidents d'Otta
sosont soumis à c ce calvaire ds
dedeux semaines et ça ne se
tetermine pas. On perd énonormét
d'd'argent, l'économie perd de
l'l'argent et on a des
ororganisateurs de convois qui
veveulent seululement déstabilir
lala démocratie et l'économie
cacanadienne.
- - On a l'impression que le
gogouvernement est paralysé, qul
nene sait pas par quel bout
prprendre ça. C'est un problèmee
popolicier, oui, mais il pourrat
y y avoir un autre plan. Qu'en
pepensez-vous.
- - On a le sentiment d'assisteà
unune impuissance généralisée. n
nene voit plus le premier minise
dedepuis plusieurs jours.
AuAujourd'hui, 45 minutes
d'd'engueulade dans la période e
ququestions, mais sinon il n'y a
eueu aucun événement public
auaujourd'hui. C'est comme ça
dedepuis plusieurs jours. Le
féfédéral a du mal à s se concer
avavec les autres paliers de
gogouvernement. Les sources
féfédérales que j'ai sont
ababasourdis par le refus de la
papart de Doug Ford de se réunir
avavec le fédéral et la ville
d'd'Ottawa sur ce dossier-là..
OtOttawa est quand mêmeme une ve
onontarienne. On voit en Alberta
quque mêmeme lorsque Jason Kenna
cécédé au camionneur, à a accélr
lele calendrier du déconfinement
popour l'Alberta, ça n'a eu aucn
efeffet.
- - Ils sont encore là  à C Cou,
efeffectivement. Mais le premier
miministre de l'Ontario, il sait
cece qu'il se passe. Est-ce que
c'c'est parce qu'il a peur d'ête
peperçu comme étant contre cette
momouvance de gens qui disent
ququ'ils n'en peuvent plus des
memesures sanitaires? Est-ce que
c'c'est pour cela qu'il reste
cacaché?
- - Doug Ford serait la vie
nanaturelle des camionneurs. C't
unun brave type de banlieue. Mêe
sisi les millionnaires, il donne
l'l'impression d'êtrtre de la ce
trtravailleur. Ces électeurs sot
bebeaucoup plus sympathiques au
cacamionneur que les électeurs s
lilibéraux du fédéral.
MaMais il est insulté par les
cacamionneurs au mêmeme titre qe
JuJustin Trudeau on a l'impressn
quque Doug Ford, pourquoi êtrtre
aiaimé est très s important, esn
pepeu paralysé par cette
sisituation.
- - Il m'arrive de me demander e
quque Monsieur Trudeau pèrere at
fafait dans cette situation. Je
pepense qu'ils avaient dit : ce
sosont des pleutres. Je ne peux
papas m'imaginer qu'au bout de 0
jojours, Monsieur Trudeau pèrere
seserait encore en train de sonr
soson monde, de renvoyer la bale
d'd'un bar et de l'autre. Il y a
ququelque chose de totalement
susurréaliste. Le Canada n'est
ququand mêmeme pas une Bendali.n
prprincipe, il n'y a pas beaucop
dede pays au monde qui pourrait
totolérer que ça dure comme ça.n
fifin de semaine, ils vont arrir
avavec des jeux gonflables, ça
dedevient ridicule. Je ne connas
papas la façon de sortir de ça,
mamais il va falloir
évéventuellement, je pense que a
vava par une manifestation de
force. Qu'est-ce qu'il y a à
nénégocier? La survie du
gogouvernement?
- - Y a-t-il un espace pour une
nénégociation quelconque, mais
avavec qui négocier?
- - Je ne vois pas que le
gogouvernement fédéral puisse
cécéder maintenant, mêmeme s'il
avavait envie de lever
l'l'interdiction, l'obligation
vavaccin pour les camionneurs, l
nene peut plus. Peut-êtrtre que
c'c'est du bail de nos états uns
didisait que ce n'est plus
nénécessaire, ça pouvait donnerà
JuJustin Trudeau le prétexte de
fafaire la mêmeme chose, mais ie
pepeut pas céder devant des
prpressions qui sont presque une
foforme de terrorisme.
- - Josée, pas de négogociation
popossible dans votre esprit?
- - L'obligation vaccinale, c'et
unun prétexte. C'est amplement
dodocumenté que le noyau dur, ce
sosont des gens d'extrêmeme dro,
cocomplètete, financée trèss
gégénéreusement. C'est de la
sésédition convois en ce moment.
PaPas de négociation avec ces
gegens-là. . Le ver dans la pom,
etet le Toronto star l'a rapporé
mamardi, c'est que le chef de
popolice d'Ottawa, il y avait ds
reresponsables fédéraux qui lui
auauraient demandé avant, parcee
quque les organisateurs
clclaironnaient sur les réseaux
sosociaux qu'il voulait occuper
OtOttawa, et lui ont demandé
d'd'ériger un périmètrtre de
sésécurité pour protéger. C'est
clclassique. Au moins empêchches
cacamions de s'installer. Le chf
dede police d'Ottawa ne l'a pas
fafait, c'est très s grave. C'et
unune erreur pour laquelle on pe
auau Canada depuis ce temps-là..
MaMais le mal est fait.
MaMaintenant, que faire? Je ne
susuis pas expert en sécurité,
mamais avant d'appeler l'armée,l
rereste sûrerement à m mettre cs
gegens-là s sous arrestation. Cs
gegens-là b brisent la loi, ils
cocommettent des méfaits et il a
dedes forces policièreres au Ca,
dedes escouades antiémeutes
foformées pour ça qui pourrait
trtrès s bien rentrer et les
ararrêtétés, tout simplement. Sy
a a de la violence, ce sera de a
viviolence qui viendra des
prprotestataires. Ça ne viendra
papas de la police. Pas besoin e
fafaire remarquer les camions
apaprès s ça, les clés vont être
dededans ils vont pouvoir partir
avavec. Il y a des choses à f f.
CÇa ne peut plus... Justin
TrTrudeau est aujourd'hui que ça
nene peut plus continuer. La
phphrase suivante qu'il a dit,
c'c'est : je vais continuer à
coconsulter discuter. Non, nonÇa
n'n'est plus tolérable! C'est la
popolice ou l'armée, mais commee
didit Michel, c'est ce que ça va
mamal se terminer. Le problèmemt
quque le chef de police d'Ottaw,
sasa stratégie, c'est d'essayere
nénégocier le retrait des camios
unun camion à l la fois.
- - Il a réussi un peu
auaujourd'hui, mais Josée,...
- - ces gens-là, , c'est pas la
vavaccinationMais les mesures
sasanitaires qui les intéressen,
c'c'est de déstabiliser la
dédémocratie canadienne, c'est
clclair. Il n'y a pas de
nénégociation possible.
- - Est-ce que le fait qu'une
sosortie de députés comme Joëlle
LiLight bande, qui dit que son
gogouvernement et son premier
miministre ont trop divisé et
jojouer de la vaccination comme
cicité une arme politique, est-e
quque ça ne m'est pas juste être
enen position de faiblesse pour
gégérer tout ça?
- - Oui, la sortie de Lightbonde
sisidèrere, parce que c'était ue
ététoile montante du Parti
lilibéral. Très s partisan. Il i
esest arrivé de m'envoyer des
flflèchches lorsque j'écrivais s
lilignes qui déplaisent au
gogouvernement. C'est comme si y
chchevrette s'était érigé en
rerebelles contre Bernard Landry
dadans le temps.
- - Ça met Trudeau dans quelle
poposition?
- - Il doit se sentir poignardé
dadans le dos. Pour moi, c'est
l'l'expression d'un ras-le-bol
trtrès s poussé de la part de
LiLightbond, un ras-le-bol parté
dadans l'équipe libérale à O Ot,
ququi ont l'impression qu'ils ne
sosont pas écoutés et vu par le
prpremier ministre. Ce n'est pas
lele seul exemple qu'on a vu cee
sesemaine de députés qui
prprovoquent une crise parce qul
enen a assez de se faire ignore.
- - Il en a assez de voix que sn
prpremier ministre n'est pas
cacapable de régler le problème.
SiSi ça s'était terminé très s e
OtOttawa, Lightbond n'aurait pas
eueu tous ses états d'âmeme. Jee
l'l'ai pas entendu pendant la
cacampagne électorale quand
MoMonsieur Trudeau à f faire dea
vavaccinationMais objet de
popolarisation. Je pense que
LiLightbond est très s content
d'd'avoir gagné les élections il
n'n'aimerait pas se retrouver ds
l'l'opposition. Je trouve ça un
pepeu cheap d'arriver comme ça
alalors que ça fait des mois que
MoMonsieur Trudeau est accusé
d'd'utiliser la vaccination.
- - S'affaiblit Monsieur Trudeau
auaux yeux des gens.
- - Il y a une certaine
mamalhonnêteteté intellectuellez
MoMonsieur Lightbound, parce que
lala vaccination est l'outil
prprincipal que nous avons conte
lala COVID. Est-ce que c'était e
lala politisation ou un geste
reresponsable? Pourquoi ne dit-l
papas non plus que les
coconservateurs utilisent
popolitiques lisent aussi la
vavaccination en s'étant opposéà
lala vaccination obligatoire das
cecertains domaines d'activité?
EsEst-ce qu'il essaie de sauver
soson comté dans la région de
QuQuébec où justement cette
momouvance monte, et on le voitu
prprovincial avec le parti d'Érc
DuDuhaime. Est-ce qu'il se sent
memenacé dans son comté aussi et
ilil essaie de conforter le
didiscours de victime chez ces
gegens-là? ? Je ne le sais pas.s
jeje suis tout à f fait d'accor,
c'c'est une gifle en plein visae
dede son chef.
- - Je vous fais vous faire
enentendre des extraits
auaujourd'hui, Monsieur Legault
ététait furieux, il reproche à
l'l'opposition de jouer là-d-des
enen disant : au lieu d'arrêtet.
vovous dîtetes que le gouvernemt
n'n'a pas été clair que ça créee
lala division dans la société.
ANANDRÉ FORTIN, leader parl.
dudu Parti libéral du Québec
- - Le gouvernement, par exempl,
dede son côtété, doit prendre ae
ququ'il y a une certaine
popolarisation en ce moment,
ququ'il y a de plus en plus de
gegens qui se posent des questis
etet d'êtrtre encore plus
trtransparent.
GAGABRIEL NADEAU-DUBOIS, chef
paparlementaire, Québec solidaie
- - Je n'ai pas de recette
mimiracle. Ce que je sais,
c'c'est qu'il faut prendre soin
dede notre démocratie, il faut
prprendre soin de notre débat
pupublic, il faut prendre soin
dede notre cohésion sociale
paparce que des déclarations
cocomme celle-là, , puis surtout
cece qu'elle reflètete comme étt
dede tension, c'est inquiétant.
PAPAUL ST-PIERRE PLAMONDON,
chchef, Parti québécois
- - C'esest une crainte qu'on dt
prprendre très s au sérieux.
OnOn l'a vu ailleurs dans
lele monde, ce genre de menace-à
pepeut déraper rapidement.
FRFRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
prpremier ministre du Québec
- - Le Parti libéral et le Parti
ququébécois sont désespérés.
C'C'est totalement irresponsable
dede venir cautionner des gens i
memenacent de prendre les armes
cocontre les consignes sanitair,
enen disant : "Ils ont un peu
raraison, c'est la faute
dudu gouvernement."
E Écoutez, là, , ça a pas de bn
sesens! On va prendre toutes
leles mesures avec les policiers
popour protéger les membres
dede notre gouvernement, pour
meme protéger. Mais j'espérerais
avavoir l'appui des oppositions!
- - Qu'est-ce que vous avez vu -
dededans?
- - L'histoire du manque de
trtransparence, les gens sont
ffâchchés contre les mesures, ps
lele manque de transparence. On
sasait parfaitement qu'il y a un
écéchéancier, c'est vrai que des
fofois il n'y a pas une étude pr
chchaque confinement, le princie
gégénéral était de diminuer les
cocontacts. Les endroits où il a
bebeaucoup de contacts, on essae
d'd'en limiter l'accès.s.
- - Vous dîtetes que l'oppositia
vovoulu faire des points facile?
- - Si l'opposition trouve que s
memesures vaccinales et sanitais
n'n'ont pas d'affaire là, , qu's
didisent ça. Mais ils disent :
dédépasser transparent.
- - Je peux donner raison à
MoMonsieur Legault dans ce sens-
llà. . Il a été très s transpar,
ilil a été présent sur tous les
trtribunes depuis deux ans.
EsEssayer de tirer profit
popolitiquement comme parti
d'd'opposition d'une résurrecti,
c'c'est une opération trèss
dédélicate et je déconsidérai à
totous les partis d'opposition
dédécide de le faire.
- - C'est comme si l'opposition
vovoulait prendre un peu de
cacapital dans ce mouvement qui
grgrandit de dire qu'il y a trop
dede mesures sanitaires, mais ss
lele dire directement.
- - C'est un jeu très s dangerex
auauquel se sont livrés les pars
d'd'opposition aujourd'hui. Ils
onont carrément fait un amalgame
enentre les menaces qui circulet
dede la part de certains
ororganisateurs, qui rapporte qe
d'd'autres personnes penseraient
fafaire des tueries tellement is
sosont désespérés par les mesurs
sasanitaires. C'est quand mêmeme
asassez grave. Le manque de
trtransparence de M. Legault das
lala gestion de la pandémie, ce
sosont deux questions séparées.i
j'j'étais Québec solidaire, le
PaParti québécois le Parti
lilibéral, je fais très s attenn
llà-d-dessus. Il y a une crise n
cece moment, il y a des fous das
lala société, des gens qui vont
pepeut-êtrtre ê